ces deux anciens salariés d'eternit tu
redouter cette décision le parquet de
paris vient de prononcer un non lieu
pour les responsables de cette
entreprise spécialisée dans la
production d'amiante
la raison il est impossible de dater
l'intoxication des salariés plaignants
conséquence aucun dirigeant n'est jugée
responsable des intoxications
on ne peut pas dire à quel moment précis
la personnalité contaminé ados chic et
donc on ne peut pas dire qu'ils étaient
responsables de l'entreprise
c'est scandaleux pour le vendre du
travail ces cas on est on est les
numéros quoi on nous fait travailler les
gens présents et puis en plus pour leurs
achats
l'amiante ce matériau utilisé dès les
années 60 est alors présenté comme le
meilleur des isolants 1200 ouvriers ont
participé à sa production dans les
usines du groupe eternit située à vitry
en charolais ou à sa transformation dans
les ateliers de saint gobain isover et
sur le site de kodak à chalon sur saône
d'autres ont été exposés à cette
substance cancérigène sans la toucher
comme les cheminots de l'atelier de
maintenance de nos verres des cas qu'ils
font de la bourgogne une des régions les
plus touchées
marc jours on a plus de 1000 dossiers de
personnes malades de l'amiante depuis la
création du rpr c'était plus 1996 tout
ce que les salariés on a pu dire
concernant eternit concernant leurs
conditions de travail
il n'y a rien non le l'ordonnancé de non
lieu
ce qui a été pris c'est tout ce qu'ils
déchargent les derniers n'ont pas de
masque qu'on avait des masques à
disposition que c'est obligatoire de
porter des masques
moi j'aime bien mon collègue japonais
que moi on n'a jamais eu l'obligation
porter des masques mon épouse nettoyez
nettoyer les bleus travaillent à les
secouer et ainsi de suite
c'est là qu'elle a commencé cancer de
l'amiante
il est tombé malade en 98 il est décédé
en 2000 la mise au taillan plusieurs
associations dont caper bourgogne ont
déjà décidé de faire appel de ce
non-lieu selon les autorités sanitaires
l'amiante provoquera d'ici 2025 3000
décès chaque année